so we had some YouTube questions come in
earlier and this is from Harry ml that's
the username how to make characters
consistent but act in surprising ways
you know writers have impulses inside
them that they often don't follow
because they want to stay on track with
an outline or they want to stay on track
with a be cheat or a plan and or they
have expectations for what is
appropriate for a certain story or a
kind of genre that they're writing and
so they ignore the impulses or the
intuitive thoughts that they have the
imagination sparks and those are the
things when you surprise yourself with
an idea you need to embrace it
you know whenever something comes up in
your mind you know we self censor a lot
and we're like well I mean he can't rip
her shirt off right there and it's just
like no it's gotta be something else and
it's just like well maybe he does and
maybe she like grabs his wrist after
that because any other leg and then what
happens then what happens then what
happens then you're going down the
rabbit hole and you're making things up
and you're surprising yourself that's
how we create you know characters
obviously you know we want the character
to still be the character is would the
character maybe want to rip the dress
rip the shirt off or whatever or grab
the paint can and or run out of the car
and start running out of the field when
they were supposed to stay in the car in
the outline and then they started
running toward the football field when
you started to write it are you going to
allow that to happen and I think we know
we're understaffed to listen to their
instrument listen to their imagination
you know you don't talk about
imagination a lot and when we talk about
the craft of screenwriting we don't
really talk about imagination like what
that is and like how we like what if but
if that whole thing
and we don't cultivate that because it
really is so messy and so nonlinear and
spontaneous that it's hard to write a
book about it like it's hard to organize
a system Abhijeet or a formula about
imagination and but that really is how
you create on surprising revelatory
behavior it's sort of like and then what
if this happens and you're just like oh
my god you know we were talking about
the meg and and how people like kind of
just you know are like I'm not gonna see
this shark movie with Jason Statham and
it's a genre movie like silly stupid
movie right but there were a couple
moments in there that were completely
surprising and I thought a plus that
stuff that doesn't happen in movies
where it's like the audience completely
fell into a lull and then the plot went
left and and it was like and it wasn't
like oh give me a break it was like oh
this is plausible and it's arresting and
it's a surprise
and it very likely probably came from
the imagination of their author going
well and then they thought of it and
they thought why not let's try that and
and and embracing it because initially
you come up with something like that you
go ooh you know an audience we like what
you know so it you know I think that
that's what it is it's like paying
attention to your own impulses and
listening to your own voice you listen
to your own voice and and not have it
and let it be the primary thing in the
in the creative act of your screen of
your script then you're then that will
allow for these surprises to happen it
reminds me of when sharp objects first
came out I didn't see it when it first
initially came out but I watched
people's reactions on Twitter and by
seeing that then I was like okay then I
want to see it
because they were like shocked and let's
assume these are real Twitter accounts
right people word they couldn't believe
it you know amy adams can play so many
amazing characters but she was playing a
damaged character that was so fun to
watch right right right so a so
absolutely I mean that's what we want to
do and and that all comes from someone
being being allowing themselves to be
creative you know you've got to say like
you know I'm gonna just have her like
run out of the car and now and that's
gonna totally screw up my outline but
it's really cool but it could maybe I
could have a lot more work to do because
I'm making this decision but I'd rather
do a lot more work and not be lazy and
embrace it you know because it's really
revelatory and awesome but people don't
want to do that they're like if I ever
do that then everything screwed up and I
want to so I'm just gonna stay on course
on the most under thing that's not
surprising and people are predicting
because I'm predicting everything
because I'm following a road map you
lose the road map and you start flying
by the seat of your pants
that's like what's gonna happen I don't
know what's gonna happen you know do you
think that's really laziness or that's
wanting to be again the teacher's pet
versus the Johnny Rotten in the backs
you know that well of course it's fear
of course there's fear of like oh I need
to do it this way or it's not gonna work
out but I hopefully I think mostly
writers and they won't upend their
outline or they won't up and their plans
or whatever I mean a lot of them will
say well look if it goes off my script I
always embrace it but I don't know I
don't I mean I think I think a lot of
people I think we write outlines a lot
of times to make the process faster but
at the expense of something being more
surprising and revelatory a lot of
things don't need to be outlined if
they're character-driven you can sort of
discover a lot of a lot of really
special moments in a story by just
seeing where it goes heist movie a
murder mystery that becomes more
difficult to just sort of follow
character impulses because you've got
more of a puzzle to figure out it's like
okay how does this gonna work but you
know
you